[Music]
when faced with a big challenge where
potential failure seems to lurk at every
corner maybe you've heard this advice
before be more confident and most likely
this is what you think then you hear it
if only it were that simple
but what is confidence take the belief
that you are valuable worthwhile and
capable also known as self-esteem add in
the optimism that comes when you are
certain of your abilities and then
empowered by these act courageously to
face a challenge head-on
this is confidence it turns thoughts
into action
so where does confidence even come from
there are several factors that impact
confidence one what you're born with
such as your genes which will impact
things like the balance of neuro
chemicals in your brain to how you're
treated this includes the social
pressures of your environment and three
the part you have control over the
choices you make the risks you take and
how you think about and respond to
challenges and setbacks it isn't
possible to completely untangle these
three factors but the personal choices
we make certainly play a major role in
confidence development so by keeping in
mind a few practical tips we do actually
have the power to cultivate our own
confidence tip 1 a quick fix there are a
few tricks that can give you an
immediate confidence boost in the
short-term picture your success when
you're beginning a difficult task
something as simple as listening to
music with deep bass it can promote
feelings of power you can even strike a
powerful pose or give yourself a pep
talk tip 2 believe in your ability to
improve if you're looking for a
long-term change consider the way you
think about your abilities and talents
do you think they are fixed at birth or
that they can be developed like a muscle
these beliefs matter because they can
influence how you act when you're faced
with setbacks if you have a fixed
mindset meaning that you think your
talents are locked in place you might
give up assuming you've discovered
something you're not very good at but if
you have a growth mindset and think your
abilities can improve a challenge is an
opportunity to learn and grow
neuroscience supports the growth mindset
the connections in your brain do get
stronger and grow with study and
practice it also turns out on average
people who have a growth mindset are
more successful getting better grades
and doing better in the face of
challenges tip 3 practice failure face
it you're going to fail sometimes
everyone does
JK Rowling was rejected by 12 different
publishers before one picked up Harry
Potter
the Wright brothers built on history's
failed attempts at flight including some
of their own before designing a
successful airplane
studies show that those who fail
regularly and keep trying anyway are
better equipped to respond to challenges
and setbacks in a constructive way they
learn how to try different strategies
ask others for advice and persevere so
think of a challenge you want to take on
realize it's not going to be easy except
that you'll make mistakes and be kind to
yourself when you do give yourself a pep
talk
stand up and go for it the excitement
you'll feel knowing that whatever the
result you'll have gained greater
knowledge and understanding
is confidence
[Music]